how's my hair looking in March I said
us-china trade was all talk no action
now it's all yelling no action the
yelling stems from American tariffs on
up to 450 billion dollars in Chinese
imports tariffs are a mistake it would
hurt American consumers they would hit
Chinese companies which have done
nothing wrong along with the predatory
companies China does heavily subsidize
its firms while enjoying open
competition practiced by others it
steals and courses a transfer of
American intellectual property it
promises to improve but it never does we
should respond to that just not with
tariffs the US should target large
enterprises owned by the Chinese
government
the Communist Party wants these
enterprises to dominate the Chinese and
global economies because they are owned
by the government they can be held
responsible for policy the US should
start with a small group of bad
offenders with regard to IP they should
not be allowed to do business with
American consumers or companies they
should be hit with global financial
sanctions this maximizes the pressure on
bad Chinese actors without taxing
Americans it's more focused and more
justified than tariffs what do you think
about the u.s. responding to China with
Terris let us know in your comments also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI